[Music]
in unique name news submitted by long
Duk dong a woman with a very strange
name decides she won't change it just to
make other people happy
Oh what's her name like fat [ __ ] it's
you like Vietnamese yeah eh-eh-eh-eh-eh
is not a real last name it is or it's a
first name I think there's [ __ ] though
yeah bi CH yeah that's a first name big
but yeah it's like pronounce big doctor
she just became a doctor okay doctor
marijuana Pepsi vendetta's oh she's a
master troll and I love her she just got
a PhD in coal the studies huh colas
teddy oh no she didn't because she got
Hep C that's that's not which one's her
first name marijuana last name is Pepsi
her last name was Pepsi but I think the
van Dijk is for her married name Oh last
name as marijuana Pepsi I thought she
got sponsored by the van dyke
refrigeration huh she should have named
her salt pepper so when she got a doctor
degree she would have been dr. pepper
she didn't think that far ahead
that's crazy that it's marijuana and not
Mary Jane yeah so her mom said that she
just really wanted she had high hopes
for her she thought that by having a
very unique beautiful name that it would
take her very far I thought she was like
my daughter's too smart what can I do to
hold her back in life and I'm gonna give
it the stupidest name I could think of
and somehow she still made it good
that's like the Johnny Cash song dude he
named you sue because it made you a
hard-ass you guys hear that song yeah
that's it
I thought her mom was just a STONER yeah
that's what she said that a lot of
people thought that my mom but she
actually has two sisters and their names
are Joe cocaine and heroin no they're
actually really nice yeah it's like
Stephanie in Ross and Kimberly what the
[ __ ]
it's your name Robin that's two
different two sisters is it spill like
Mary wha no no no Mary Joanna like the
real way
marijuana marijuana she's not even
Spanish no I just showed you there's
black Spanish you point but not have you
heard of the country of Belize no she's
from Wisconsin
marijuana is a Spanish word but uh but
yes so she's 46 so she's lived with this
name her whole life but she loves it
she's just like I think it's beautiful I
love my first name being referred to as
marijuana well she has no [ __ ] choice
that's our [ __ ] NIC it's better than
what we marry
huh she could just be Marian's like hi
Mary so that's exactly what I wanted to
bring up so her teachers in school would
always try to make her feel more
comfortable or like fit in a little bit
better so they would change her name to
Mary and she's like no my name is
marijuana too many syllables I can't say
it to my god nobody calls them buddy
bother full my full name is Christie no
I don't get called Kristina you know
yeah you really know that Italian name
was Christina Christina Dominican the
middle Canadian yeah Christina yeah I
like everyone's just one syllable Steve
TIFF Joe Chris Gio but but we all have
two syllable names right except for
Steve four syllables Steven it's spelled
like step three shoe plus silly probably
got called marijuana so much that when
she hears merits weird cuz when you call
me Steven I'm like who the [ __ ] is that
like I think he's mad at you you screwed
me too when people come if aney I
enjoyed this myself as Tiffany I don't
know why because it sounds weird and
people call me Tiffany it's not right I
don't know I just got used to TIFF I
don't know but for her she said that her
up until she was nine years old
her name was completely normal like
there no one made her feel weird about
her name like I grew up in a weed farm
you should go for the coolest kommune
ever she's from Wisconsin that's all I
know but she did say that they in
moving when she was 9 in that and when
she moved that's when things were weird
for people around her they're like what
why would your parents name you that
like I would never name my kid that and
like just made her feel really bad about
her name that makes sense cuz other kids
are not gonna even know what the [ __ ]
her name is make sense no one ever
brought it up no one knows what the [ __ ]
of a bad name though marijuana like
imagine if her name was like Coors Light
you know me like Pepsi perhaps it'd be
pretty close everybody knows what a
Pepsi is so that's like oh you sleep I
rather have Pepsi than coca-cola like
the name you know like hey coca-cola
come from GMC like what where does that
name come from like what how did they
come I think it's a neat practicum
arowana Pepsi but the funny thing wait
so the last name Pepsi what if that and
that's where Pepsi came from it was
someone's last name like it was a common
name or whatever
mr. Pepsi or whatever right that's right
maybe yeah cuz I'm like which came first
the drink or the name did you almost
have a name like he could have been yeah
well I Lopes Waterloo Payne yeah you're
almost a river yeah what's the short for
Guadalupe just looping Wow Lupe bother
yeah those guys were Guadalupe too
doesn't that mean the mother Mary the
Virgin yeah that's why my mom wanted to
name me that because her due date was on
her birthday like mmm we celebrate her
birthday and December 12 and so that was
her due date but I ended up being born
two weeks early and so my dad got to
name me Tiffany because we like Tiffany
company for guys that are named like
Luke Lupe right is it Guadalupe ball no
same name I love you Christina and
Christina you know yeah right that's
what I was thinking I like the guy
version of it dude I named my
when I was seven years old is when my
baby brother was born and I named him
Kenny after a kid on my soccer team oh
you got to name your brother yeah dude
is the kid on the tiger too as I pitch
it to my parents really well so so
there's a kid all the toys I did us all
really well so I those kid my soccer
teammate named Kenny who's a fairly sick
kid right and so I was like oh would
that be a good name like a little kid or
he's like he was dope he was dope Oh
physically ill okay so then so then I
pitched it to my parents I was like okay
think about it like this we're all
upstairs and you're calling us for
dinner and you go Jennifer Stephen
Nathan Kenney
and they're like wow that's pretty good
I think we're named after your kid sound
like it fits though see that's how I
sold it so when my brother says when
they're like oh why they pick Kenny my
brother um my brother's another guy on a
soccer team even after Steve Jobs that's
sick he has to say a soccer kid that's
crazy like my parents I don't know my
mom she named my brother well Mitchell
is just um off of she really liked the
name was a crush he had in high school
but she liked that guy's name Mitchell
but then Jordan was from Michael Jordan
so there's always somebody like somebody
like a celebrity or something that near
like Steve Jobs or yours well mine
that's actually just my dad cuz my dad
my mom named my brother so when I was
born my dad wanted to name a name me so
I'm just my great-grandfather's name it
was this big oh [ __ ] man and Ray my
middle name is king hey there so there
was this big controversy in Japan like a
while back this couple named their kids
Satan yeah wait cuz then you wouldn't
matter because they just thought it
sounded cool no I mean they knew what it
meant the English word Satan or legit
was like saying seitan like it's not
literally Satan like the like the devil
but yeah and then it's like a big
controversy right and in like people
were just like what the [ __ ] and then
you look at the family and they look
like this cute little normal family and
they know what's the Bukit in their
future what is Satan
yeah well Lucifer's on it
like does he have like a bowl haircut
he's smiling holding a balloon I don't
know it's just kind of weird like why
would you name your kid that well that's
what she thought a lot about name of
market mega mega mega like mega man mega
Sosa sound tired make it so so my son
thought that people said mega like cuz
one time he came up to me he was like
mom why do people say mega I'm like what
do you mean like yeah like mega please
and I'm like oh no that wasn't cute it's
like six years older 7 the best safe
word like yeah where is he going around
his people just saved it although it's a
bad house oh I'm saying watch movies
that would have the word okay because
it's not in our home so that sound like
well where were you get it from yeah
there is something out there where
people talk about like the name can can
shape the personality also Lisa wouldn't
say megger I want to name my kid skug
for that exact reasons god yep that's
actually a cool sounding dog sounds like
a lazy stoner dude he'd come out like a
[ __ ] truck driver yeah that's my
picture right oh yeah
so harm stud trying to troll my stepmom
and she was pregnant and he was like
yeah we're gonna name him cuz I'm not
beautiful
I'm like what what did a spell entice 12
he's like no he said I don't know if
this is true because this is what he
told me but he said that that's the name
of popes house the pope's house custom i
Boogle i'm their fault I don't know so I
was like maybe the Porta Potty I don't
know but that should cracked me up every
time he said it I'm like no way you're
naming my brother that he ended up
naming him after himself which was
Gustavo
but yeah named Gustavo sounds powerful
like like the villain in in a novella
you know me
Gustavo's have to wear capes I feel you
should wear capes dude you could rock
home you know yeah it's nice to hate my
name's like now it's cool but like in
school it was like every every the first
day of school
roll call whatever's Cristina I would
say Cristina and then I get laughs so
like it's Christine oh you mean that's
funny because I got Bonnie which is the
guy version of my name I wanted to meet
my brother Giovanni like Remi they ended
up naming him Remi but I was telling my
mom like monster Bonnie sounds so cool I
really like that how about couch cuz
you're comfortable I told you your name
and your kid [ __ ] paper clip
I called no you guys made up that name
that's too many syllables
once the couch it's a call up yeah one
syllable sounds pretty cool this would
never let you eat food I like that flu
flu flute flute yeah oh oh how would you
spell that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]